[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain the second part of the action
sci-fi movie parasite spoilers ahead
watch out and take
[Music]
care movie begins with the police using
a serial killer named uragami to
identify mysterious aliens that have
invaded the humans these aliens are
called the parasites and infect the
humans by entering their brains these
parasites take over the human
consciousness and turn them into violent
cannibals the police are hopeful about
identifying the aliens through origami
who has witnessed the parasites feeding
on humans before they bring shinichi
before the serial killer but he fails to
identify him after being let go shinichi
continues to hunt down the parasites who
terrorize the humans for food with the
help of migi the parasite that affects
his right hand although shinichi is
still a human he is progressively
growing stronger because of migi using
his powers he effortlessly takes down a
parasite feeding on a human in an
abandoned building after killing the
alien shinichi feels someone's presence
outside and rushes to inspect however he
fails to notice an investigative
journalist named shiro kuramori hiding
behind a pile of junk the city's mayor
takeshi hirokawa who has also been taken
over by the parasites grows worried
about shinichi killing the aliens he
complains about shinichi to ryoko tamiya
the leader of the parasites but she
forbids him from going after the boy
tamiya who now is a mother to a human
baby intends to use shinichi and migi
for her research on the parasite's
coexistence with the humans afterwards
hirokawa meets with another parasite
named goto goto is an extremely powerful
parasite as his body is made up of five
different parasites goto advises
hirokawa to kill shinichi it is then
revealed that kuromori was hired by
tamiya to spy on shinichi he hands her
the evidence he has collected so far and
suggests they should give it to the
police
however tamiya advises him against it
saying they need more information on the
boy kuromori who is a single father of a
girl named yumi has grown close to
tamiya over time he relates to tamiya
who is also a single parent and agrees
to continue to gather more information
on shinichi shinichi eventually catches
kuromori following him red-handed with a
camera and confronts him migi asks
shinichi to kill the reporter but he
refuses to kill a human after learning
that tamiya had hired him to spy on them
migi tells the reporter that she is a
parasite herself and much more dangerous
than other parasites shinichi and migi
tell kuramori that he is playing with
fire and advise him to stay away from
tamiya and keep a low profile kuromori
is in utter disbelief but decides to
continue his investigation he goes on to
interview the mayor hirokawa about the
parasites
afraid of being exposed hirokawa orders
his men to kill the reporter after the
interview meanwhile migi senses the
presence of five parasites nearby while
returning home from school megi advises
shinichi to run away however they are
eventually caught and to their
astonishment they learn that they are
faced with a man that has five monsters
in his body a cat and mouse chase
follows after reading the man's brain
waves migi advises shinichi to kill the
original monster using his speed
shinichi then swings by a tree and
beheads the monster they then run away
and the man again comes back to life the
parasite in the man's right hand who is
revealed to be goto takes the place of
the head and orders the parasite in the
severed head miki to occupy the right
hand when kuromori returns home he finds
police in front of his building
panicking he runs to his apartment to
learn that his daughter has been killed
by the parasites who had come looking
for him kuromori is traumatized by his
daughter's death and refuses to
cooperate with detective hirama
meanwhile tamiya is furious to learn
that the parasites tried to kill
shinichi and kuromori she expresses
regret over the senseless killing of
kuromori's daughter she fears that
senselessly killing humans could give
rise to an uprising strong enough to
exterminate all parasites she then
threatens to kill hirokawa and the other
parasites herself if they again try to
undermine her authority ever since
tamiya has given birth to her human son
she is increasingly exhibiting more and
more human instincts such as kindness
and going above and beyond to care for
one's own child she breastfeeds the baby
and tries to make him laugh by making
funny expressions
detective hirama learns that kuromori
has fled from the hotel where he was
kept under police protection and
immediately heads out to look for the
bereaved father with his unit
swearing revenge kuromori kidnaps
tamiya's son and leaves her a note
calling her to a park so she can see him
kill her baby tamiya immediately rushes
to shinichi's home to seek his help
however shinichi isn't home and she runs
into his girlfriend satomi satomi gives
tamiya shinichi's number tamiya explains
to him on the phone that she is not
responsible for the parasites coming
after them and asks for his help to save
her baby as tamiya and shinichi arrive
at the park to meet kuromori the
japanese special assault team s.a.t led
by yamagishi starts preparing to raid
the town hall to kill all the parasites
after learning the truth about hirokawa
the city's mayor people inside the
building are ordered to vacate the
premises they are made to undergo an
x-ray scan and the monsters identified
by the x-ray machine are executed on the
spot after evacuating the civilians the
sat team then storms into the building
and corners hirokawa after finding
himself cornered hirokawa goes on a rant
against humans calling them the real
parasites i guess hirokawa had been
watching the matrix
but yamagishi cuts his monologue short
and sprays bullets into his body to his
astonishment yamagishi realizes that
hirokawa is actually a human hirokawa
was helping the monsters because of his
principles and beliefs just as the armed
men begin to wrap their heads around the
revelation the last remaining parasite
goto shows up the s.a.t team bombards
the monster with bullets and he blocks
them without much effort at the park
tamiya explains to kuromori that she
didn't order the killing of his daughter
but kuromori blinded by revenge refuses
to believe her shinichi also tries to
persuade him against harming the
innocent baby however kuromori is
hell-bent on avenging his daughter's
death as he proceeds to throw tamiya's
son from the bridge the police arrive
left with no other choice tamiya kills
kuromori and saves her son exposing
herself in the process kuromori falls to
his death and the police point their
guns at tamiya shinichi is stunned that
tamiya exposed her identity to save a
human baby's life instead of running
away tamiya starts walking towards
shinichi with the baby detective hirama
warns her against taking another step
but she continues to walk towards
shinichi and the police sprays her with
bullets clinging to her last few breaths
she hands the baby to shinichi and tells
him that she doesn't wish to run away
because she doesn't want her son to live
the life of a fugitive she asks shinichi
to look after her son before collapsing
and passing away shinichi breaks into
tears because he doesn't want to take
care of this stupid baby but also
because tamiya reminds him of his late
mother satomi arrives on the scene and
comforts her boyfriend as detective
hirama proceeds to take shinichi for an
interrogation he is informed that the
sat team is dead he immediately rushes
to the town hall with shinichi at the
town hall goto throws yamagishi's
severed head before harama angered
hirama shoots the parasite but it
deflects the bullets back at him killing
him on the spot the police retreat while
sensing danger to his life shinichi
flees in a car
goto follows him on a motorbike and
eventually catches up to him before
shinichi and migi can even realize goto
jumps on top of his car and attacks him
migi drives the car as shinichi tries to
dodge the parasite's attack a long
struggle follows and migi eventually
loses control of the car and it drives
off a bridge however migi manages to
save shinichi and itself goto sustains
injury but also survives the crash and
starts chasing the two into the forest
megi comes up with a plan and they
decide to ambush the parasite migi
attacks the parasite from a tree and
shinichi sneaks up on him from behind
but the parasite tanks their plan
left with no choice migi asks shinichi
to run away as it keeps the parasite
busy shinichi refuses to sacrifice his
friend but migi forces him to go goto
eventually kills migi and shinichi runs
away shinichi seeks refuge in an
abandoned building and calls satomi he
is devastated by miki's death because
playing with his hand in his room will
never be the same again and satomi
comforts him she reminds him that he
still has her and this is not the end
the two then start making out the next
morning shinichi discovers that a part
of migi is still in his right hand due
to his body being infected with migi's
cell in the previous part of the film
migi had used its cells to repair
shinichi's heart damaged by a parasite
shinichi also realizes that if migi is
still a part of his body goto can use
that to track him he freaks out and
proceeds to flee with his girlfriend
however the parasite catches up to them
to save satomi's life shinichi reveals
his location and lures goto into a
garbage disposal facility a battle
follows goto badly batters the boy but
even without migi he holds his own he
grabs a metal rod and stabs goto with it
but barely does any harm to him goto
then proceeds to kill shinichi but
suddenly migi comes to life it is
revealed that migi had not died it had
transferred to goto's hand megi returns
to shinichi's right hand and goto starts
disintegrating because of the toxins
released by migi in his body
at last the final monster goto's torso
with a beating heart remains migi
reveals that there's a 50 50 chance of
goto surviving refusing to let that
happen shinichi proceeds to kill the
monster but suddenly remembers tamiya's
words that these parasites are just
trying to survive on earth like the
humans but shinichi ultimately decides
that even if the parasites are just
trying to survive he must protect the
ones he loves he tells the monster that
humans may not be perfect but they
deserve to live before throwing it all
in the fire a few days later as shinichi
does his homework migi tells him that
since all the monsters have been killed
there's no need for it to be around
anymore
migi says that if it stays around it
could only cause problems for shinichi
with the authorities migi intends to go
into hibernation for several years
decades or perhaps till death and in
return shinichi will get his right hand
back shinichi is heartbroken to hear his
plans to leave but migi tells him that
it is time for them to walk alone
migi thanks shinichi for everything
before turning into a normal hand as
shinichi breaks into tears some years
pass by shinichi and satomi meet to
visit tamiya's son taiki tamiya the baby
seems to be fond of the two and runs to
them afterwards shinichi goes to buy
coffee for satomi urigami the serial
killer from earlier in the movie watches
him leave and uses the opportunity to
kidnap satomi taking her to the top of a
building shinichi notices him and
follows him to the roof the deranged
killer holds satomi at knifepoint and
states his belief that all humans are
monsters because they have been killing
each other since time immemorial uragami
who thinks that chinichi is a parasite
then asks him for his opinion shinichi
proceeds to reveal his identity to the
killer but satomi discourages him from
doing so angered the killer pushes her
off the building shinichi runs to save
the girl he punches the killer and
extends his hand from the edge of the
top however satomi is beyond his reach
all the time he has spent with satomi
flashes before shinichi's eyes suddenly
he realizes that he is holding satomi's
hand and pulls her to safety as they
breathe a sigh of relief shinichi
figures out that migi momentarily woke
up to help him save satomi
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching